it's always a sign surefire faith when
the Tom Hardy venom Eddie Brock himself
going out there going my favorite part
is nowhere to be seen you ain't gonna
see that [ __ ] I'm Susan the best parts
of this movie are not available on your
local theatres October 5th what's a good
reason to go see it to build up
anticipation from when those scenes when
they drop on the DVD extra hey reject
nation it's Greg Alba and I'm John we
have some movie news things to talk
about we're gonna talk about Jake
Gyllenhaal kind of looking like Mysterio
we're gonna talk about some more better
venom news cinema let's start off with
the spider-man bit of footage here
they've released set photos of Jake
Gyllenhaal as Mysterio where he looks
exactly like he belongs in Asgard like
from afar especially his armor looks
just like their chest plate yeah and the
Cape you gotta take this with you no
screw that don't take it with a grain of
salt this is 100 percent accurate you
know I love videos that do commentary on
these kind of pictures because you know
you got to take it 100% literal that
this is what the final look will
actually be oh yeah this is the complete
context this is this is everything that
you need to see those wires are gonna be
in the shot that's they're not gonna CGI
enhance any of the costume department
I'll be honest though when I first saw
this I was like okay uh that looks
alright but then thinking about it if
you're gonna adapt the Mysterio costume
into a real-life movie this is actually
not too bad of an idea right here you're
gonna want to see photos with Jake
Gyllenhaal without the mask on the
fishbowl helmet what we're getting here
in terms of just the the costume design
it's not bad I was expecting a lot
greener maybe in the actual
post-production they're gonna really
green that bad boy up yeah but what
we're getting right now it looks like a
struggling special effects artist which
is who broke into the Wardrobe yeah it
looks it looks like that to me and we we
did a video a while back about a stereo
being in spider-man homecoming 2 or from
you know I expressed a lot of thoughts
about
how I'm kind of hoping for something a
little bit more meta references that are
a little bit of a commentary on comic
book movies thinking about it too with
Peter Parker of that beginning of
homecoming with him vlogging sort of
breaking the fourth wall with what this
movie is and someone who's really into
pop culture you know with all Star Wars
references the geeky side of him this
could work really well it could be a
really fun villain for Jake Gyllenhaal
to do and looking at this outfit it
seems like it's on that track and I'm
hoping it has a sense of humor about the
outfit yeah my hope is that the movie
actually opens up with masti recording a
vlog of his own just from inside the
helmet because that would be really easy
I mean you've got some of the earmarks
of the classic cause the first thing I
noticed I were I looked for was the the
clasps that looked like eyes you know
for his cape and stuff like that reading
up on this this makes me curious about
what approach they're gonna take
ultimately cuz there's been speculation
about like we don't know if these photos
are gonna be CG later if they're gonna
borrow from the ultimate spider-man
version cuz that's a very different
version of the character he doesn't have
the fishbowl helmet yeah I guess this is
making me excited to just see which
direction they decided to expected
fishbowl helmet because look at the rest
of the outfit yeah for sure it seems
like they kind of take bits from column
a bit from column B and kind of mash
them together if I had a criticism that
I feel could be a little more warranted
here you do guys take these with a grain
of salt you know you never know what's
actually gonna look like when you see an
actual trade letter even oh that looks a
lot better I'm not a fan of the fact
that Jake Gyllenhaal looks really
good-looking because if you've seen
Mysterio aquitted back in most versions
I don't recall version where he looks s
handsome as that guy no mad cuz I was
excited for Jake Gyllenhaal going a
little bit creepy looking again that
looks like Jake Gyllenhaal in an
interview to me really good there and
beard maybe that's part of some wardrobe
thing he's got going on maybe he's in
some makeup design I was looking forward
to Jake Gyllenhaal having some like bad
haircut and looking more than a night
crawler Jake Gyllenhaal song is like oh
you look creepy that's why this looks
very ass guardian to me superhero do you
think perfectly quaff yeah I'm kind of
speculating that maybe he starts off
looking more like the Quinn in bed
that I'm more familiar with I remember
in the 90s animated show and Mysterio
appears his framing spider-man and all
these things maybe this is all part of
his new due to make himself appear like
he's a hero for all I know because that
that would work in that context if this
is Quinn him back throughout the whole
film looking forward more to less great
looking Jake Gyllenhaal maybe maybe
these pictures are just after a point
the movie where he gets a major boost of
confidence he's feeling a lot better
about it because he's got this newfound
status everyone's afraid of him so he's
like oh you I'm finally brushed my hair
it looked good for the job but yeah it's
a cool photo glad we could and can see
it can't wait for the official trailer
yeah but let's move on to the news I
really want to talk about here the venom
news just keeps getting better and
telling you guys I've said it in a
couple of videos now at best this movie
is gonna be entertaining ly cheesy in LA
I don't know what other parts of the
world are like would venom haven't you
away LA I am constantly bumping into
people who are like I don't know about
that movie man that's probably gonna be
bad and suck and I always in the
conversation with I cannot wait to watch
this movie
oh yeah I'm just so curious to find out
what this film is gonna be like if it's
entertainingly cheesy or entertainingly
bad I'm all for it I've always thought
the idea of this movie sounded strange
from the get-go yeah there's already a
weird quote that has sort of been taken
out of context from director Ruben
Fleischer that said way back in
September 2018 and when he was asking
about a director's cut he said I
wouldn't rule anything out we'll have to
see where it lands I guess but I
wouldn't rule anything out so a lot of
people have taken that as he's really
planning a director cut yeah but that's
not what he's saying here but saying he
wouldn't not do it then you got this Tom
Hardy quote here which I love he's not
gonna call him books explained he was
asked what his favorite moments in the
movie are and he says there's scenes
that are in this movie they're like 30
to 40 minutes worth of scenes that
aren't in this movie all of them mad
puppeteering scenes dark comedy scenes
you know what I mean
they just never made it in it's always a
sign sure
faith when the Tom Hardy venom Eddie
Brock himself going out there going my
favorite part nowhere to see you ain't
gonna see that [ __ ] soon the best parts
of this movie are not available your
local theatres October what's a good
reason to go see it to build up
anticipation from when those scenes they
drop on the DVD XP which is great home
video market because I don't know how
much this coincides with them switching
from R rated to pg-13 I know Ruben
Fleischer originally wanted to make it
r-rated but then you know he came out
with some other quote I feel like the
director especially has gotten flack
from the studio from like this is just
my guest there's obviously no sources
confirming this he says some [ __ ] that
gets him in trouble Amy Pascal shows up
is like hey safe face then he has to
come out and be like no that's we didn't
make a pg-13 to try to get venom in the
MCU you started this mess make me your
flunky to get you out yeah I don't know
how much whatever they cut cuz every
movie goes to reshoots especially the
big ones and I know this one we went
through a lot of extensive reshoots as
well it seems like they tried to change
something fundamental about this movie
at some point I don't know like there's
small things you can remove to make a PG
third like an R into a pg-13 but just
the vibe I've got enough of all this
news plus the aggressive amount of
advertising they've done especially
riding on things that we heard about
from comic-con and then not showing them
completely like you know venom bites a
guy's head off but he doesn't really you
know yeah I want to see venom not by
people's heads off but a lot of
implications that he's biting people's
heads up I'm like yeah I get it don't
show us imaginations better that works
great for horror movies but when you
bring venom to life again and making up
for the last time that no one was
satisfied with I think we want to see
some of those extreme elements so yeah I
don't know I just wonder what inspired
that decision if it was anything other
than yeah let's get them in the MCU I
don't know it doesn't matter at this
point I mean those are some of my
favorite movie going experiences like
you said when you're like I don't know
what this is gonna be like at all
yeah I can't wait to find
hey you know I like a lot of movies that
people don't like simply because of how
she lucky or cheesy they are my
trepidation is that the last two times
I've felt this way I walked out of those
movies really not having had fun and
that was the Megan that was Jurassic
world too
well this this story with Tom Hardy
reminds me a lot of Jason Statham with
the Meg because he had a whole interview
to if you look at what both Tom Hardy
and Jason Statham are saying about these
movies that arguably would have worked
better off of an r-rating and had a lot
more fun and excitement that could
probably be backed by an r-rating they
both are say things that are essentially
boiling down to I signed up for a movie
and then now watching the movie it
wasn't the movie I saw both of them are
saying kudos man I think that this could
be a really interesting time at the
theaters we're gonna do a movie review
most likely a spoiler talk of the movie
as well I just don't know who this movie
will spend it's funny because I don't
know it's like you know to do a venom
origin tale without spider-man and then
people come in going but you know venom
does get his own comics or it becomes a
protagonist and then I go yeah but
Venom's whole origin was virtually a
very big villain in the whole point and
becoming a protagonist there's a path of
redemption from all the villainy
activities yet really twisted and alter
this whole thing but hey we'll find out
this week this coming weekend right oh
not this week this weekend this week oh
boy that's right Thursday night on the
dot well what do you think of this news
are you more excited for Jake Gyllenhaal
to play great looking Quinn and back or
are you more excited for a movie that
Tom Hardy is obviously disappointed this
is a comport subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification about the
subscribe button suck and you can check
us on patreon we've got TV show
reactions Q&A is a whole bunch of posts
going up there usually every day we'd
love to have you come to tragic